[Music]
so was it been Sam five six years since
you even won a race it's been a long
time since you was somebody
don't push it Jack let him hey don't
take my word for it past your side I
told him not to push I want to win races
I want to be a champion but that's
something I'll never be racing for my
day
[Music]
got a whole bunch of talent son come on
up and talk to me
what's on your mind since it an offer
from Bob Lenski I'm not gonna race you
anymore
let's get he's a snake you get involved
with Alexa him and I guarantee you'll
get hurt
championship means more than your father
[Music]
dirty damn shame I got an idea why don't
you and me go racing
sale would you do that blues your father
landscape right off the credit family
while the women championship and I want
you let me tell you something no
half-assed measure who do it right
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
stumpy you were out of your mind
in October 1989 43 women around the
world gave birth none of these women had
been pregnant when the day first began
how much do you want for it
I have adopted six children
gifted with abilities far beyond the
ordinary I give you the Umbrella Academy
does anyone wish to speak it was a
monster everything about our family is
insane I always had
[Music]
is that my skirt oh yeah this it's very
breezy on the bits I see nothing's
changed
I jumped forward and got stuck in the
future you know what I found
absolutely nothing what's it supposed to
happen in eight days there was someone
out there who's trying to stop me from
preventing the apocalypse we need the
full force of the academy bingo
yay sisters yay sisters
get up we're going we're save the world
oh is that all
you
how does it feel William I never went to
secondary school
because looking server you do katakana
is not the wealthiest school in the
district but it's down to each one of
you to decide your own level of
commitment the rains came late this year
and now the trees are gone Malawi is
preparing for a very long hungry system
DNA recorded a single vehicle at sea but
Oh golly mondo and colors of honor
William Ali Bey Armenian get it and easy
what are you going to do
anything you it's a poem can you fix it
maybe mr. fetch a window when you turn
the wheel on your bike
the light changes
it's not let's you can bring water I
know how to do it
[Music]
of invisible school mr. weed I know the
electricity we can plant in the dry
season and offer cozy wozy Manasa
[Music]
Malusi italic elite news attack attack
30 million attendees
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you gonna talk about
[Applause]
and delivers awkward
[Music]
you
have you ever walked home at night with
your keys between your fingers listen
over your shoulder for footsteps when
you enter a public restroom smile at
someone who frightens you because maybe
if you're nice enough maybe they won't
actually hurt you
hi look I read all the coverage what's
your name
Dakota Haggerty you're safe now they're
ask you the child
I don't know what you're talking about
but whoever you're looking for it isn't
me
they're any questions about your
assignments your grades as Max my GA
I know there's something happened to you
maybe I'll tell you about it sometime
what are you doing tonight
let me working there to O'Shea's grab a
drink that sounds nice maybe somebody's
pulling a harmless prank
either way you're fine someone's trying
to to do what I'm telling you someone
was there
I think someone's stalking me and that
maybe Kurt put him up to it we could be
talking to Kurt he's locked up in his
cell it isn't the professor with the
parents what do you mean
before he came to teach err he's
involved in this massive court case
shouldn't you be studying bring a
country right
you oughta where you can just hang it
here for example he's the one that's
been doing all this to me
stalking me threatening me I can't eat I
can't sleep I hear footsteps like
there's nobody there someone has been
torturing me
we knew the threats and wins me
hey max is here thank you followed me
here would you here with me right in the
very beginning a car taught me that the
hunt was part of the thrill
sweetie they spelled California wrong
tell us Sonia onwards and upwards right
so la here we come you have any idea
we're going doc the door I'm looking for
123 and a half
I'm Judy wood that looks like you found
it I need some help you do with that
what do you know about immigration law
no wait don't answer that
I don't have time to be your mentor but
real cases are always the best teacher
I'm Judy wood Judy wood Judy I have some
friends
[Music]
mrs. wari I'm sure you would your new
attorney the law of asylum only protects
you if you were part of a persecuted
group if we can prove that then we have
a very good case but you must tell your
story I was arrested because I wanted
everyone to know that girls to think for
themselves the law of asylum does not
recognize women as a protected class her
male relatives become duty-bound to
protect their family honor I'll kill her
as a woman I applaud you
has a judge I must rule against you we
have a compelling basis for appeal we
just need a rock-solid brief for the
Ninth Circuit we need to look at every
case every legislative commentary come
on he's never had all your lunch because
you save it for your clients I was
thrown in jail honest and I was thrown
in jail here but in America I can fight
back yeah a nation of immigrants like my
father it's a beautiful day we don't get
many of these around here you have one
last chance
[Music]
that's a clear conscience nothing to
papers
respect that I see
take the sunscreen you know even if you
win you lose everybody is gonna want a
miracle from you
you can't save them all I can try
give me something silver Li
[Music]
[Music]
you